let's talk about aoc uh so the big met
gala was yesterday and i'm told guys you
can correct me if i'm wrong on this uh
michael i might be i may be mistaken but
are we in the middle of a pandemic
worldwide pandemic very serious stuff
connor have you heard about this thing
people wearing mass everywhere all right
so my guys have heard about it
supposedly there's this crazy pandemic
happening where everyone's in masks
nightmare death everywhere yet for some
reason the progressives managed to all
show up to the met gala yesterday
dressed mostly as clowns actually we'll
show you some well let's just we have an
image or a video of aoc what do we got
let's throw something down
video of aoc rich what a model aoc what
up i didn't know you model as well damn
oh my god aoc tax the rich what a motto
oh my god god these people are awful so
just to be clear this is a 30 000
per ticket event okay we're in the
middle of a pandemic you'd think that
maybe these people wouldn't be flaunting
their elitism uh aoc of course she is
the worst type of elitist because she
already is an elitist right she's never
done anything other than become a
congresswoman to me you don't get a lot
of credit for that especially the way
she did it by by sort of just using
america against itself she rails against
capitalism and freedom and everything
that is good but she has no problem
partying with these people and yes i get
it but she's but dave she's she's
telling them tax the rich she's saying
fight the power uh no she's doing this
to just troll everybody like if you
think trump was a troll aoc is aoc is a
vile vile troll because she's trying to
destroy the very system that has allowed
her to become relevant as disgusting
maybe capitalism isn't great someone
like aoc could become relevant aoc did
not pay for her ticket by the way
masks were only required inside but as
you can see in some of the videos
masks were not required inside even for
the or masks were not required inside
for the attendees like aoc and the other
elitists but all the staff that was
serving them had to wear masks and i
mentioned this
when i was away uh in mexico during the
break that i was at a resort where the
guests did not have to wear a mask and
all the staff did and it really was
making me think we're going to end up in
a class war too i mean there's so many
things wrong right now but this mass
thing's
going to become a class thing that the
people working to serve the elite will
be put in mass at the resort i was at i
told every single person that brought me
a drink or served this dinner i said you
don't have to wear the mask for me and i
would ask people to just smile
occasionally and nobody wanted to take
their math down they want to keep their
jobs but this is what someone like her
is she will hobnob around
multi-multi-millionaires and
billionaires and by the way i don't
think they're inherently bad because
they have money they're probably pretty
decent people who in many cases are very
philanthropic and pay most of the taxes
we'll get back we'll get to that in a
sec but she does that while trying to
destroy the very thing that allows these
pathetic reporters to slobber all over
her as she's saying tax the rich but
i thought we'd do a little a little
research on this tax the rich so do we
not do we not tax the rich in the united
states i mean is it true that the rich
aren't paying taxes and everyone else is
well we've got an image from something
called the irs this is the internal
revenue service i think these people
know something about taxes from what i
understand and i want you to really look
at this image and perhaps you'll
screenshot this and send this to other
people because aoc says that we that you
know this is what they always say this
is what bernie says this is what
dementia joe says this is what they're
always saying that the the rich have to
pay their fair share the rich have to
pay more etc etc i want you to look at
that top right area so if you look at
top five to ten percent top two to five
percent top one percent we got 11
16 21 uh they're paying basically 50 of
the taxes so if you're making over 152
000
which is a significant amount of people
they're paying about 50 percent of the
taxes is that not their fair share
is that not their fair share the top one
percent
those are people making over 540 000
like you're doing real well that's great
you're probably doing something
worthwhile they're paying 21 so the top
one percent pay 21
if you're making over 152 000
you are basically paying 50 percent of
the taxes and i'll let you guys analyze
this for yourselves but do you really
think they're not paying their fair
share do you think that we're not taxing
the rich and do you think that perhaps
if we tax the rich more just so that
people like aoc will have more money for
her ridiculous government programs that
just waste and accomplish nothing and
create a bigger and bigger state that
does nothing other than suck off all of
us and not suck off in the good way do
you think
do you think do you think uh that she's
just using this as more power that she
can give to herself to wear her
ridiculous dress and throw it all in our
face like it's just
so obvious i don't like aoc
have i made myself clear on that i don't
like yeah that was clear okay